Hi Joe and that we're live.
Thanks for doing this.
Appreciate it.
Thanks for having me.
It's a very fortuitous your timing comes right in the middle of this big hubbub
about um,
this a native American elder and this young boy with one of those stupid fucking
red hat's on.
Yup.
That would you have ever imagined that a slogan like make America great again
would be so divisive as somehow or another like that that would be like make
America great again.
What sounds like they just want to make things great like no positive,
no.
And a red hat with white letters.
Has there ever been a time like that where an object,
like a red hat with white letters was so repulsive to half the country?
Yes.
Well,
I mean some people see it as the equivalent of a white hood.
Wow.
I don't know about that.
I think,
I believe they do
wearing it,
wearing it that a 16 year old wearing that hat sort of carries intense moral
weight that surely we know that a 16 year old is not aware of all the things,
locations of wearing that hat.
Yeah.
But the problem with that is Kanye wears it.
Right?
Fair enough.
It doesn't really work.
I agree.
I'm just saying there are people who really make that argument.
I get it.
I know that people who are paid for their opinions,
well yeah.
Well there's also people that are calling for this child's name and address or
calling to docs him and publicly expose him.
This is a child these 16 is that what he is?
He's 16 years old.
And
one of the things that was just so amazing about the whole Brouhaha realm,
I mean it was in a way like this perfect encapsulation of our outrage culture,
right?
Because people saw a tiny clip of this video and it was like a roar shock test.
Yeah.
You saw in it this morality play of what would it look to be,
was a group of mostly white kids from Coventry Catholic school.
I think it's in Kentucky.
And it looked like at first glance that they were smirking and smug and had
these sort of shit eating grins on their faces and that they were surrounding
this older native American man.
And I have to tell you,
I had a visceral reaction to it.
The second I saw it,
like so many other people,
I was like,
this is,
you know,
where we are in our broken culture and they're bullying this guy.
And here's the rise of the,
I had all of those reactions.
The challenge of what it means to be a journalist is to not see people as
signifiers or as stand ins just based on their identity.
And that's what like 94,
95% of the press corps did.
They sort of leapt to the leap to assume that,
you know,
our visceral reaction was accurate when in fact when you actually looked at like
the two hour video of the whole interaction,
which also included this group of black Israel lights are Hebrew Israelites,
they called themselves.
It was not that at all.
The native American man had walked up to this group.
The four other guys had been the group beforehand,
calling them crackers,
calling them Satan,
calling the one black kid in the group,
things that can't even be said.
So it was just far more complicated.
Um,
and what,
what was really,
really disheartening is that the out,
the initial outrage was enough for the mainstream press to report on it.
Like Twitter has kind of become almost an assigning editor for places like the
New York Times and the Washington Post and the Wall Street Journal.
And then when the actual truth of the thing comes out,
when we move past the outrage cycle,
they have to sort of write the followup story to the fake outrage to begin with.
I'm defending the fake outrage instead of backing up and saying we made a
mistake.
Right.
Well some people said that they made a mistake.
That's wonderful.
That's a good sign.
Yes,
it really is.
But one of the things that was so horrifying was that people that are supposed
to be adults,
you know,
people with blue check marks on Twitter.
We're saying things like this is the face of white patriarchy,
the 16 year old kid,
or raise us on set.
Have you ever seen him more punchable face?
Kathy Griffin was saying,
I need names.
Shame him.
Doc's him.
How do these people not understand the implications of that?
So what happened over the weekend was that the,
you know,
sleuthy detectives on Twitter found a kid who they thought was the kid in the
video,
wasn't actually the kid.
So there's the actual kid who was docs.
The family was harassed.
Everything that we now know happens in these outreach cycles.
But then there was another kid who looks suspiciously like him who was not him
at all,
whose family.
There was an amazing and heartbreaking Twitter thread about it,
whose family was in the middle of a family wedding and they dispend their whole
weekend fighting off these mobs who were trying to destroy them.
And it wasn't even the kid in the video.
I mean that is really horrifying to me that that's where we are.
And the fact that adults who should know better or fomenting this and don't see
how thin like the Vin,
like it sounds heavy,
but like the veneer of civilization is like they're taking a pickax to it.
It's just,
I just found the whole thing to be terrifying.
I don't know how you felt.
Argument.
Same Way.
And I think it's a very unique moment because it's so public and it's so,
it's so prevalent in whether it's Twitter or Facebook,
it's everywhere.
And it sort of embodies everything that's wrong with a lack of nuance and with
people taking one side versus the other and sticking with it with not
confronting their own personal biases with looking at these things through the
eyes of this is the enemy.
I'm on the good side.
They're on the bad side.
Yes,
let's get them.
And also this,
this distorted idea of what it takes to what it takes to be violent.
Like this idea of this is a punchable person like calling for violence.
You,
you're,
you're hearing a lot of this.
Like,
this is one of the things that troubles me so much about the left.
My family,
my parents were hippies.
Um,
you know,
I grew up when I was a little kid,
we lived from age of seven to 11 in San Francisco during the Vietnam War,
while the Vietnam Nam War was ending,
I was living in the middle of the hippie world.
I always felt that people on the left,
we're like these well-read,
kind,
compassionate people,
but somewhere along the line within the last few years,
people on the left are calling for violence.
This is very,
this is very confusing to me and it's,
it's this frivolous social media call for violence.
It's not an in person,
be their boots on the ground call for,
but it's a very strange call for Violence Punch Nazis.
I'm hearing this all the time because it's right because it's,
sorry,
go ahead.
What I'm going to say is what does a Nazi okay is if you mean punch actual Nazis
that are putting Jews in the concentration camps,
I'm with you,
but when you call a guy with a Maga hat on,
he wears one of those red hats and he's just an asshole.
He's a Nazi.
Now,
some guy who maybe he's not that educated,
wants to be a contrarian,
sees all these liberals that are complaining all the time,
so it puts this red hat on and now he's a white supremacist and a Nazi and you
want to punch him like,
okay,
it is.
That's what a lot of people in very high positions of power in this country,
at least in the culture,
actually believe,
and they don't understand the implications of hollowing out words like that.
Yes,
I know this personally,
right?
Cause I'm called alt right.
Um,
I'm called an apologist for rape culture.
I've been called everything.
I'm a centrist.
Okay.
I'm,
I'm a Jewish center left on most things person who lives on the upper west side
of Manhattan and you know,
it's super socially liberal,
liberal on pretty much any issue you want to choose.
If I'm alt right,
what,
what words do we have left for people that actually are that exactly what words
do we have left for people who actually are part of a sort of racist blood and
soil nativism that's rising in this country and around the world,
that should terrify people that are using that language in the sloppiest of
ways.
I really don't think they're seeing the implications of it.
I also think that when,
when you're just,
you know,
your keyboard warrior and you're just tossing this stuff out,
so much of it is about signaling to your tribe that you know that this thing is
bad.
Yes.
And I really don't think people are understanding the implications of this and I
don't think it's a stretch to imagine something like this happening a week,
two weeks,
a month,
two months from now and someone actually getting killed.
Right?
Like Charlottesville.
I mean very,
very similar to what happened this,
this,
this kind of,
I mean when that guy drove over those protesters,
the ramping up of the dialogue on both sides of the rhetoric,
the violent talk,
it's so disturbing and so unnecessary,
especially when it's disingenuous.
Like calling someone like you outright or me cry.
I'm a,
I get called alt right adjacent.
That's when I hear that one all the time.
I'd go left on everything basically except guns.
There's a few things that I'm like repeal the second amendment.
Yeah.
I mean,
but I,
I do think that there should be some restrictions for gun use.
Just like,
I think there should be restrictions for car use.
I actually think there should be testing for guns and you should have to go
look.
Do you have to go through a fucking,
you have to take driver's Ed to get a car license.
How come you don't have to do any,
you know,
you don't have to do anything to get a gun like you once.
If you're not a criminal,
you just get a gun.
Like you don't have to know how to take care of it and clean it and safely
handle it.
You don't have to know the ethics of use.
You don't have to know anything.
I know it's insane.
I mean at night just spent six weeks in Australia where they had basically what
major massacre 20 years ago.
And then,
uh,
I forget who it was.
We could look it up.
But you know,
prime minister conservative got rid of guns.
Yes.
Everyone in the country that they think we're insane and psychotic the way that
we live.
Well,
we're definitely weird.
Um,
the thing also,
one other thing that that
jumped out to me about the,
the Catholic school boy incident,
it kind of signifies something broader that's happening,
which is the eraser of the individual,
which is just,
I think,
a horrifying problem in our culture.
Like what actually happened was a one hour incident on a random afternoon in
January between a group of individuals.
Right.
But instead in our mind,
why was everyone there?
It was this boys or were there for the march for life.
Um,
I don't know why the Hebrew Israelites were there,
but it's DC,
like they're crazy protesters all the time.
You know,
at the Lincoln memorial and outside of the White House were there for a school
event,
is that what were there for the march for life as part of their school and they
had like been had free time,
I think.
And then we're signing converging at the Lincoln Memorial.
They didn't have a chaperone.
There's no,
no.
I think the teachers,
there was a teacher there and they had asked the teacher at one point in order
to drown out the heckling of the Hebrew Israelites.
I hope I'm getting the name of that group.
Right.
Could we do a school cheer to kind of ignore them?
Um,
and they did that and I think they did that with permission from the teachers at
one point.
Early on it was rumored that they were chanting build the wall,
but no one has surfaced any evidence of that whatsoever.
Well that's what I heard from the native American elder when he was talking
about it in a village,
in a video.
He said they were chanting out build that.
Right.
And maybe they were,
I just haven't seen anything.
And I've watched every video.
It's totally possible.
They're also 16.
Right.
And you're also trying to make their friends laugh and they're assholes and
they're just being silly and stupid.
Right.
And I have to say as like someone who was a nerd in high school,
I saw the face of the main kid in that still photograph and that video and like
the 14 and 15 year old girl in me was like enraged.
Really.
Like I was like,
I see the face of so many kids who said the nastiest things to me and who
through friends of mine into garbage cans,
like the Blake disgusting bullying.
Was it because you think is you have to get to the next step if you're a jerk?
No,
we was.
It was,
yeah.
Oh for sure.
Just standing there.
It's the hat.
It's the face.
Maybe even still if it's a group,
but he put the,
my thing is like your initial reaction to something is not the truth.
It's your emotional reaction and anyone who calls themselves a journalist like
your job is to figure out the facts of the case,
not to make this into a kind of identitarian morality play and the fact that so
many people in so many publications did just that.
And in fact when the real facts surfaced,
just kind of sort of dug their heels in and were basically like,
well he's a stand in for the white patriarchy.
What?
That's crazy.
Like there was an actual buzzfeed writer that said it's the look of white
patriarchy,
his face.
You're really going to put that on a 16 year old would we?
Like,
it's just,
that's nuts to me.
Well it's cruel.
Um,
it's a denial of the individual.
It's very cruel.
When you're 16 years old,
you're basically a baby.
You don't know what the fuck you're doing.
You're incredibly susceptible to the influence of your peers.
You're around a bunch of other boys,
you not around girls cause you don't go to school with girls cause he goes some
wacky religious school,
right.
That this is,
you know,
you want to really be a social justice warrior.
We really want to save the world.
How about you do something about the Catholic Church?
Everyone wants to go after our Kelly,
which is great,
but how about the Catholic Church?
How about the number one kid fucking organization of all time?
That's what it is.
And I,
I was raised Catholic.
I know what it is.
Did anything happen?
Nothing happened to me.
I got lucky.
But I know people,
I know a bunch of people and know a bunch of people with stories and this is all
over the world.
These kids come from that cult.
Imagine if that was not the Catholic church.
If it was instead Scientology,
we would be getting all these kids are a part of a cult.
They went there.
They are a part of this weird cult that suppresses sexuality amongst its priests
and encourages the placement of these pedophile priests in new places in order
to get away from whatever crime they've committed in the area where they were
initially established.
This is what the Catholic church is,
right,
but,
and they travel all over the place,
but it also is good people.
This is the,
this is where nuance comes into play.
It's good people.
There's a bunch of people that are Catholics because they want a better
relationship with,
with God or the universe or love or whatever.
They feel like it's a good moral framework for their children.
They take them there.
They in the 10 commandments,
they believe in this moral structure for society that's laid down by what they
believe is God.
There's great people that are involved in the Catholic church,
but it's also the number one kid fucking organization in the world.
It's those two things,
right?
So these kids are a part of something that's way worse than smirking at a native
American with a drum.
And in my opinion,
being ivory,
when I was 16 I was a fool.
I was a dumb person.
No,
I was bullied.
I was little small and I learned martial arts when I was like 15 I mean I'm sure
it was a dick to some people just cause I get away with it.
I don't,
I don't really remember it,
but I'm definitely differently.
People are dicks.
You're trying it out,
you know,
you don't even know how to talk yet.
You basically just learning words.
And this kid with this guy beating the drum inches from his face,
he handled it,
I believe way better than I would.
I don't think I would have.
I don't see,
I mean,
I don't think so.
No,
No one knows 16 pop pop.
When I was 16 also,
I was competing,
I was doing a lot of martial arts events,
so maybe I would have kept it together better than I'm,
I'm thinking I would have,
but I definitely was a fucking idiot and I was 16 you know,
you just don't,
and who knows what's going on van day,
who knows?
Like if you have an anxiety about the future or your girlfriend broke up with
you or you failed the test or what else that is like bouncing around inside your
head,
overwhelming your ability to form reasonable thoughts.
Six.
It's assumed by the way that everyone's initial,
not everyone's every liberal.
I know.
Okay.
Everyone on the center and center left and even the center reits reaction to it
was accurate that he was a little asshole,
right?
That he's a racist,
homophobic,
transphobic,
hates immigrants,
every single thing.
Does that deserve to be news that a 16 year old kid with those fuse smirked at a
native American elder?
Especially considering what he actually did know.
I don't think that's news.
Not only that,
I think it's strange that we're covering it like it is and because of the
Internet,
the fact that we're my timeline on Twitter and on Facebook and on everything.
This was way bigger news then day,
whatever it is,
30 31 of the government shutdown where people are having to get on bread lines
to feed their families.
Right?
Who's the thing is it like,
but it's people what it's what people want to talk about.
I think there's this idea that there's things that are happening right now like
the government shutdown and then there's things that are happening right now in
terms of our culture shifting and when these things that come up in opposition
to what many people believe is a beneficial shift to a more progressive,
more responsible culture.
When these little hiccups,
they get addressed and they get address rapidly.
And I think it's because people are aware that things are changing in this
almost like unprecedented way.
If you look back unprecedented pace,
I agree with you.
Yeah.
Like nothing we've ever,
there's nothing that you could find in the historical record for human beings
has ever been.
What we've experienced over just the past 10 plus years of social,
um,
social networks and social media and the ability to spread information very
quickly with a youtube video or a tweet or whatever.
I mean,
these,
the way people are exchanging information is,
is very different.
And because of that culture is shifting at a hyperspace speed.
It's just turbocharged for sure.
So I think when something comes up that we think is like,
ah,
there's one,
get it.
Exactly.
But it's not logical.
It's like,
it's like road rage.
You know why you get road rage?
One of the reasons,
because you're going fast.
Okay,
you're in a car and you're nervous.
You're,
you're heightened senses.
So anything that happens,
it gets magnified like someone's mother fucker in my lane to Hong Kong because
you already jacked up to eight because you're in a car going 60 miles an hour.
Wait,
Twitter does that.
Twitter's doing that.
Social media is doing that.
Life is doing that,
this.
So when something like this comes up,
this rapid pace of change,
which is almost an impossible to keep up with,
right?
With the new cycle and this constant wave of change and information.
So when something comes up,
people are road raging on this kid.
Totally.
That's why we just have to,
I mean,
there's,
there's lots of things to say,
but one thing,
it's just continue to insist on truth and facts and not allowing people to be
stand ins for a group.
You're not a standard for anyone.
You're yourself.
You answer for yourself.
And I just,
I find that trend on both sides really,
really scary.